is CNN. Right now we're
following multiple
investigations of Donald Trump
as legal pressure on the former
president reaches new levels
tonight. We're learning from
court sources that a New York
grand jury won't hear the trump
hush money case during the rest
of this week. CNN's senior legal
affairs correspondent Paula
Reid, is just outside the
courthouse in Manhattan for us,
Paula, what does this tell us
about the status of this
criminal investigation? Well
wolf. It's clear the prosecutors
believe they have more work to
do before they bring this case
back before a grand jury and
move on to a possible vote on a
possible indictment. It's also
unclear if they're going to call
any more witnesses before the
grand jury. We know the grand
jury heard from David packer,
the former head of the company
that publishes the national
enquirer on Monday. That came
exactly a week after defense
witness attorney Robert Costello
testified. And we learned
through our sources, the
prosecutor's office was
considering whether they had to
bring in additional witness in
to rebut Costello's testimony.
One of the people under
consideration was also Michael
Cohen. At this point, we don't
know if any more witnesses will
go before the grand jury or how
long it might be before they
move us onto a possible vote,
but will likely be back here
next week, and we'll wait and
we'll watch certainly will. On
another investigation. Paula the
special counsel investigating
the January 6th insurrection.
There's now a new ruling, saying
the former vice president Mike
pence, must in fact testify
under oath. That's right. This
is a multipart decision because
here, the vice president who has
ruled he must testify about
conversations he had with former
president trump in the lead up
to January 6th and this is
significant because
investigators have described
this pressure campaign that
pence was facing from trump and
his allies not to certify the
results of the 2020 election in
Biden's favor. There is one
particular call that multiple
witnesses have testified about
on the day of the capital attack
where the former president
launched a pretty vicious attack
against his advice president now
he will have to testify about
those conversations with the
same judge has ruled that he
will not have to answer
questions about his official
role as president of the senate
on January 6th. Pence raised
this protection under the
constitution, the speech or
debate clause, saying that he
should not have to testify about
anything he did in his official
capacity. This judge agreed, but
this is another win for special
counsel jack Smith has had over
a dozen wins, as he has really
pressed to get answers from
witnesses in this investigation
. Major win indeed, Paula, I
want you to stay with us. I also
want to bring in CNN legal
analyst normalize it into this
conversation norm. Let's begin
with the news from the grand
jury in New York. What do you
think is the cause of this delay
this week? Well wolf when you're
gonna put the president ah, in
the criminal doc, which there is
every indication the district
attorney is considering. You
want to make sure you have it
right. We know that the
president chose a witness to put
in the grand jury. Bob Costello
. Then we know that the
prosecutors brought a rebuttal
witness, David pecker. So now
they're deciding what to do.
Well having litigated case
against the president, uh then
president Donald Trump. People
would often say why wasn't that
impeachment and trial going
faster? You wanted to make sure
you dotted every I and crossed
every T that's what the
prosecutors seem to be doing
here. Let me go back to Paula
Paula. So is this a sign that
prosecutors in New York still
don't feel their cases actually
buttoned up. Even after they
heard from an additional witness
just yesterday, David pecker.
Well, what we know is after they
heard from attorney Robert
Costello, they did believe they
needed to bring in at least one
additional witness to button up
their case to rebut his
testimony was a bit of surprise
for prosecutors because the
grand jury is usually it's a
prosecutor show. They call the
shots, and it was expected that
the trump legal team asked for
this witness to go before the
grand jury than they brought.
One witness is unclear if they
will bring another one, but we
absolutely know from our
reporting that they did have
concerns following Costello's
appearance about how they would
button this up right now. It's
unclear pecker is the only
witness that will bring to rebut
that testimony will have to wait
and see. You shall see norm. I
want to turn to the federal
judge's decision that Mike pence
. The former vice president must
in fact, testify about
conversations he had with trump
leading up to January. 6th you
predicted pence would have to
testify. How much of a
difference could his testimony
actually wind up making. Well I
think it's very significant and
several of the charges that jack
Smith is very likely looking at
, you know, starting on December
5th Donald Trump raised the
issue with pants of changing the
outcome in the electoral college
, and that pressure continued
like, uh, advice, squeezing
pants, culminating on the
conversation that Paula
referenced on January 6th itself
, so that is very important
proof of the toughest issue in
any criminal case. Wolf
president trump's intent at the
time to overturn the election. I
think it's very important
another big win for jack Smith.
It certainly seems like that,
but Paula pence can still
decline to answer various
questions related to his actions
on January 6th when he was
presiding over the senate, the
vice president of the united
States, according to the
constitution, is also the
president of the U. S senate. So
tell us why this is significant.
This has been a really
interesting question for legal
scholars would pence be
protected under the speech or
debate clause could. He argued
that as president of the senate,
he should be protected, just
like a legislator would be for
anything related to their job,
and it appears that the federal
courts are open to this is a
pretty exciting legal issue that
could potentially make its way
all the way to the supreme
court. What do you think, norm?
Well I think it's a very good
decision by judge Jeb boasberg.
As far as we can tell wolf. It
remains under seal. We just have
the reporting on it because the
core of pence's activity speech
and debate on the floor of
congress that is protected.
That's what the constitution
says, but that wouldn't relate
to conversations he had with
Donald Trump. Weeks before he
showed up in the chair to
preside on January 6th. I think
it's a solomonic decision, wolf
and I think it's one that will
hold up on appeal. If it is, as
we think, since the actual
details remain under seal shall
see dorm Eisen and Paula Reid,
guys. Thank you very much
important note to our viewers.
I'll be interviewing the former
vice president Mike pence later
this week. One on one will cover
a wide range of topics,
including the 2024 presidential
elections that are coming up.
And the trump investigations.